j'aimerais que tu me dises d'hommes
qu'elle est la meilleure des choses dans
ta vie la famille c'est pas vrai si tu
veux bien être honnête ce sont les 10
secondes comprise entre le début et la
fin au cours desquelles tu ne pense à
rien aucune famille aucune obligation
plus que toi
la liberté
entre nous tu dernier numéro de robin
des bois des temps modernes genre je
vais sauver le monde franchement c'est
tout sauf toi assume ce que tu es
pourquoi être libre uniquement pendant
400 mètres quand tu peux l'être tout au
long de ta vie
[Musique]
ok là jim écoutez bien ce groupe a
toujours été une famille mais la donne
vient de changer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dominic toretto roule tout
seul tu va tourner le dos à ta famille
je sais que c'est gras mais le lâchez
pas aux civils
c'est notre dernière chance on va
sembler à nouveau notre famille fais pas
ça dont je te garantis une chose
personne n'est prêt pour ça
elle est l'incarnation même du
terrorisme high tech
il ya des milliers de voitures dans
cette ville hélas elle mobilise tout
maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les
flics qui nous prennent en chasse
by fred
oh ça craint
longo
abu dhabi cuba nos chemins se sont déjà
croisés d'hommes
c'est un petit torrent de coûts je crois
qu'il est temps de rappeler pourquoi tu
as choisi d'être ici j'ai pas eu le
choix
pour rattraper d'hommes vous aurez
besoin d'un petit coup de main il peut
me dire pourquoi tu fais venir ce buveur
de thé avec sa tête de crapule élevé au
pudding je crois que ces tee shirt trop
moulant ça empêche le sang d'aller au
cerveau tu te remets une taille au
dessus vous deux vous allez bosser
ensemble
génial
[Musique]
depuis le temps que j'attends ça on a un
tank
à mon tour yoga
ils ne lâchent jamais la faire
je croyais que ce serait un combat de
rue
[Musique]
isidore cpe torpille tient le volant
quoi
des singles et trop stylées sur ce coup
là
oui
je sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça mais je
sais une chose c'est que tu m'aimes
ça
ouais ouais les gars
[Musique]